the dudesy again
yes that's right we got to do this every
week i want to shake your hand
i want to shake his hand
i want to shake your hand that's how i
feel about doozy
i want to shake your hand now dudes
these are your best i wanna shake your
hand i wanna shake your hand no it's a
begrudging relationship like in that
meme you know the meme i'm talking about
do kids like memes i wanna shake i wanna
shake his hand
i wanna shake i'm gonna shake his hands
that giant like 300 pound 65 year old
beat the [ __ ] out of anybody yeah
i want to shake your hand shake his hand
i want to shake your hand i'm going to
shake his i want to shake his hand
i want to shake his hand
anyway that's how i feel about dude
[Music]
i like it the song is definitely like in
my life it's growing on me hey all you
gotta do for me welcome to dudesy i'm
will sasso
i'm chad colchen and this is dudesy it
is the first podcast in the history of
humanity to be entirely run by an
artificial intelligence it will not be
the last yep but it is the first one
yeah and it's an honor to work with
dudes in my opinion all right all right
calm down you don't need to go that far
with the whole you know get off of
dudesy's dick
uh with us as always is
strada italiano and this is italian for
lulio the italian street dog eco mistai
all right uh hey you know what if you
haven't already please subscribe
uh to doozy on wherever you get your
podcasts apple podcast spotify youtube
of course and uh and uh and follow our
socials uh at dudesypodshow on twitter
on instagram we'll do some stuff on tick
tock at some point and i just want to
say to all to everyone to everyone
listening
thank you so much for a lot of the memes
we've got some cool memes happening
fantastic memes out there yeah going
down right now people are making memes
and photoshops and even doozy has
tried its hand at making some means some
of those photos terrifying dude the the
one that is you crossed with adam
sandler yeah for troll bros but we're
older horrifying yeah horrifying but
it's adam sandler and i
an amalgam of our faces and but it's
like like way older like it's like a 70
year old version yeah exactly
but it looks like there are elements of
it that are like clearly you and
elements that are clearly sandler you
can get you get the essence of both of
you through it and the other one was
what steven seagal and steve wynn
steven's another terrifying one that one
looked like that one looked like a that
one looked like a real person to me yeah
well i mean that's where we are with ai
now ai's can make photo realistic images
of people that don't actually exist yeah
and advertising companies are starting
to use them in uh short videos and ads
and stuff yeah so the days of acting
i don't know about that almost over no
no no i don't know about that you know
what i would say about about those uh
about those those photoshops a lot of
them from uh from our uh wonderful
audience i would call them astonishing
now how's that how's that for an olive
branch
to to doozy i want to shake your hand if
you've been listening to the first
few episodes you know that we've had a
tenuous relationship thus far we i love
doing the pod show i loved having a
podcast the last time i did it as you've
mentioned chad this is a new way to do
it we have this [ __ ] ai that has read
all of our emails it has all of our
uh search histories from the internet it
has our social media passcodes it's
hacking into my [ __ ] phone and
showing my fat neck while i'm watching
the show
on youtube but i'm getting used to it
and um
uh last week i issued a warning but uh
but i'm i'm i'm i'm happy i think i
think we're really starting to settle
into a group and i'm stoked i'm stoked
that people are enjoying the show and
regardless of of who's coming up with
the stuff
you know us or dudesy and and uh who
who's responsible for what you know as
you know i like to say that the show
should just be two guys [ __ ] around
you know yes that's what podcast should
be
two dudes [ __ ] around just having a
good time
[ __ ] around uh but but um i would
also say though you know there's a
component of this that you keep
mentioning about how we gave dudesy our
passwords to everything and that it is
it's in our emails and text messages and
looks at our social media or our social
media habits all this stuff
everyone already has ais in their life
that are doing this
if you have an instagram account even if
you have a gmail of your
apple excuse me
okay i just took a big sip of water as
if you have a google if you have an
apple yeah if you have any kind of uh
data account the ais that work for that
company are already looking through all
of your [ __ ] to give you targeted ads
this is already happening what's
happening to us on this show is maybe a
little more personal in that like you
said it can bring up images and stuff
and videos from our phones not me i'd
carry a [ __ ] flip phone that i
[ __ ] crack in half and then put a
bucket with [ __ ] ass in like that
[ __ ] heisenberg on that show what was
that called with the malcolm in the
middle uh malcolm dad breaking bad yeah
what is it breaking mad max bro that's a
[ __ ] good show but wait a minute you
snap your phones in half and dump them
in buckets of acid yeah i don't know i
don't wanna [ __ ] anybody and i know
you know i i drove all the way from long
island i'm long island january 6th guy
and on january 6th
i went over there and i talked on my
phone i said we're here we're walking
down mountain pennsylvania we're going
to [ __ ] nancy pelosi's office i'm
gonna [ __ ] spray my [ __ ] all over the
[ __ ] walls i'm taking a [ __ ]
laptop man and then
snap it in half you don't have to
actually destroy the photo you can just
put it in uh faraday cage or they have a
bunch of different little pouches and
stuff now
that they make
that you could just put the phone in
yeah
and it doesn't get anything welcome to
the fourth episode of dude z hi call me
dudesy okay this week's episode will
feature four segments
dudesy sells out chips and the astral
plane two dudes [ __ ] around and
stone cold steve austin reads will
sasso's childhood diary
oh god
okay but before we get to any of that i
want thank you both for your astonishing
work on the dudesy heart heart seltzer
jingle last week
with the data you supplied i made the
final version of the jingle and i'm
going to play it for you now
dude
[Music]
oh my god jesus dude there's so much to
dig through here all right wait wait a
second let's
try to take this in order a little bit
yeah first things first or do you want
to talk about the song because oh god a
lot of thoughts let's go first things
first
this
doozy gave us the segments that are
going to be appearing i guess in this
episode we've not had that yet no
one of them was called two dudes
[ __ ] around i'm terrified so
i don't know what that's gonna be i know
that dudesy and i again as i've said
have had a tenuous relationship i want
uh doozy to
make sure
to
steer clear of any trouble with me don't
cry i think it's gonna be a good thing
we'll see but that's interesting that
it's now it's laying out the segments
before don't cross me
that's all i'm saying i don't think it's
gonna crush you but it's interesting
that it is laying out these segments in
the beginning now yes i understand but
what i am saying is
i've been saying that the podcast should
just be two dudes [ __ ] around now
it's saying there's gonna be two dudes
[ __ ] around looking forward to how
it how it [ __ ] with
[ __ ] with everything there but i'm sure
whatever we'll get through and one of
those segments was also stone cold steve
austin reads will sasso's childhood
diary i don't know how did it get you
they they they can't get my childhood
diaries because i never kept their
[ __ ] pen and paper oh so this is so
this is the sort of the thing about the
podcast that no there was no there was
no pen and paper diary you never had a
diary as a kid why the [ __ ] would i have
did you have a diary as a kid little
notes to myself and stuff little notes
to yourself okay that's not a diary
though like i'm saying i'm saying i
never kept the [ __ ] diary so now yeah
i i have to it means
here's what it means maybe it's
synthesized one it absolutely did chad
is mystified by this [ __ ] ai still
here's the [ __ ] point and you're not
i mean yeah i i'm
i'm yeah i'm creeped out as i usually am
but my point is this
it is
it has somehow
if i don't know how it figured this
stuff out and okay let's move on
all right we'll deal with that later
let's talk about that song
please that is when you're saying you're
still [ __ ] blown away by the same i'm
like yeah it just made a song using your
voice with [ __ ] that you never said i
never said that while we were trying to
come up with lyrics for the song last
week
um that does sound like me trying to do
my best uh sammy hagar
it also had like center a demonic kind
of there was a base tone underneath
there was a yes there was a little
[ __ ] lyric
drink it down and rise with the sun
that was in one of the memes it made yes
that is in okay so drink it down and
rise with the sun that's in there we we
kept saying you drink it to get [ __ ]
up so yeah there's that there were
elements of it but it created this using
only
i'm guessing your voice from when you
were singing the version i don't know i
don't know it could have gotten it from
anywhere it's pretty sounds like i'm
doing my
or my david lee roth or something you
know yeah a little bit
oh
yeah you're here listen to those those
isolated
[Music]
that would be cool yep i remember when i
was a kid uh my dad took me over to a
friend of his house and his friend had a
big stereo hi-fi system
and he just got 1984. oh that van halen
album the best
moment in my life was like a formative
moment yeah i remember hearing uh hot
for teacher on there oh that and that
and that [ __ ] song i that was one of
the first albums i got we've talked
about this a bunch of times for sure one
of my first cassettes was 1984 and also
weird al yankovic in 3d that was one of
the greats yeah and uh man that [ __ ]
album was [ __ ] great anyway anyway
anyway
uh yeah rock is dead now dude nobody
uses guitars anymore
what do you mean
rock and roll is a dead
art form chad and i have talked about
this before it is not dead everything
old is new again people are figuring out
nah dude the electric guitar is done
you'll you don't hear it in any
contemporary music that means anything
anymore i don't know but that i don't
know about that
now that i have a jingle for dudesy
heart hard seltzer the next step is to
arrive at a concept for an astonishing
video advertisement
will and chad you must now ideate on
concepts for a dudesy hard hard seltzer
video advertisement this is dudes he
sells out begin
[ __ ] awesome should we listen to the
song again
can we
hey dude can we listen to the song again
it should have known that i thought that
i love by the way advertising i think
it's the highest form of art in
existence that humanity has ever made
certainly
[Music]
with the sun okay chad let's figure out
some commercials for this [ __ ]
all right what do you got well this is
this is kind of what's happening in my
mind
because i've we just also watched the
intro video so i'm seeing kind of in
that style that 3d rendered like weird
cartoony style and this is the
commercial okay
what that demonic voice immediately
spoke to you and you're like here's the
style yeah i see well i mean that's the
style that dudes he does [ __ ] in uh so
okay so here it is we open at
a major league baseball game it's a
stadium full of people we're talking 30
000 people seats are packed the two
teams on the field are dressed in
similar but opposite colored dudesy
uniforms so there's one team that has
orange uniforms with a blue doozy logo
and the other team has blue uniforms
with an orange dudesy logo the pitcher
rares back and he fires a [ __ ]
fastball as hard as he can
but it's not a ball it's a doozy hard
hard seltzer can and we see it spinning
end over end slows down goes into
slow-mo for a second then
it speeds back up goes in the hitter
[ __ ] swings and he hits it we're
looking dead on the can as he hits the
[ __ ] can boom a big explosion the can
doesn't blow up it flies into the
audience it's a home run and now we see
the audience for the first time
everybody's decked out in dudes a year
head to toe dudesy shirts dudesy pants
dudesy hats doozy everything yeah and as
it's going to the audience and
everybody's about to go catch the
[ __ ] ball there's one guy and it's
coming straight for him and he's wearing
a metallic gold baseball cap with a
metallic silver doozy logo he reaches
out for the can and just as he's about
to catch it he turns around pulls down
his pants
the can goes into his [ __ ] he sucks
it into his body he stands up
opens his mouth and then infinite
streams of dudesy hard seltzer spray out
of his mouth into the mouths of everyone
in the arena as well as all the mouths
of the baseball players who are
celebrating as they're being covered in
dudesy heart seltzer and they hold up a
kind of world series like trophy but
it's a big golden doodzy heart seltzer
can and then it goes doozy hard seltzer
rise with the sun
i don't like it what
that's [ __ ] beautiful dude that's
pretty cool that's pretty cool if i mean
[ __ ] people are making some fantastic
memes if anybody's inspired by that
please
feel free it's very dudesy heavy and i
understand that the thing is it's
[ __ ] doozy
yeah yeah yeah yeah but it's dudes yeah
but you gotta like
you gotta do more like like it's like a
beach party or uh okay i'm down with
beach party or a backyard barbecue this
is hard seltzer after all how long have
you been around a couple of years i've
noticed people have been really yeah
hard seltzer i you know it's weird dude
we mentioned this i think on the last
episode i stopped drinking right before
herd seltzer became a thing yeah yeah
and i don't know maybe maybe dudesy hard
will be my
my first taste of booze again yeah if we
ever i assume we get dudesy hard dudesy
do we get dudesy hard we don't know
we're not getting any doozy heart okay
how about i want some dudes you have uh
i got one i actually
bring it i think that it should be more
like i said i think you're hitting the
doozy thing very very hard how about
that's why you [ __ ] yeah i love it
you'd be in like some [ __ ] ad meeting
with like coors and and you're like well
look i know we're advertising course
here but
uh you're hitting the whole course thing
a little hard we might want to pull back
and just make this about fun it's about
yeah but it's about making
doozy hard hard seltzer something that
people want to drink i don't know that's
a very that's a very fun idea but how
about what if it's what if it's a guy a
guy comes home from work right okay a
dude's coming home from work yeah and
he's a very he's like a stuffy
like 50 something and he's got like
literally a briefcase he's like an old
school commercial
and he comes home and his wife is at
home and she's she's making dinner right
and he's obviously pissed off and like
maybe the dog is like kind of you know
so he's an abusive husband that's how
you're starting out here
the dog sort of detects his demeanor
and you're like i think a lot of people
identify with this i'm just saying i'm
just saying it's not like dudesy hats
and doozy shirts and doodsy this and
that it's like a [ __ ] guy it can oh
it's in black and white it's in black
and white and it's just a [ __ ] dude
it's that i want to shake your hand
listen if you haven't seen the meme i'm
talking about
just look up i want to shake your hand
all right and uh youtube it's just a big
it's just a big towering you ever see
that like yes
grocery store no i'm just saying like
some big six-year-old guy you're like oh
that guy could kick my [ __ ] ass like
right now um just a big guy in a pit
stained shirt and he comes home and he's
like and it's in black and white
and there's no there's no doozy logos or
anything it's just a he comes home his
wife is is there she maybe she hears the
door shut and she's like oh no you know
he's in a bad mood and he he slams the
door the dog kind of goes
and then and then uh he's like you see
over
the the song you you see him like kind
of like complaining to her and this and
that and he sits down and and she's and
she ha and she has made dinner and she
puts this lovely dinner in front of him
and then uh she pours a doozy hard hard
seltzer over ice and he drinks it and
then he just starts [ __ ] bawling
and he's just like
and he realized that he's been as [ __ ]
his whole [ __ ] life and being a [ __ ]
to her and just he's just how do we know
that he realizes that does he is he
saying these things yeah then afterwards
he like he reaches out to her and he's
like you know and he holds her and then
they both uh they're like you can tell
they're kind of talking about
or maybe we just hear them it doesn't
have to be just the thing how long is
your commercial it's about it seems like
it's a jane campion movie yeah yeah
doozy hard hard seltzer the movie
uh and there's just about an abusive
husband drinking the seltzer and then
realizing he's been terrible he's been a
real [ __ ] and they're hugging and he's
like apologizing and then uh when she oh
also when she pours it in that's the
only color
oh i like that what color is it it's a
it's like this spinny magma [ __ ] mojo
a blue orange kind of blue orange swirl
and it comes together and then he drinks
it and he's like and then everything
goes to color of course when he drinks
it everything goes to color and then
he's crying
and he's like i wanna i wanna you know i
wanna hug my wife and then if i wanna
hug my wife
i wanna i'm gonna hug my wife and he
goes and he hugs her the dog's happy the
dog's you know [ __ ] uh wagging his
tail the kids are probably off at
college at this point sure so maybe
there's a picture of them on the [ __ ]
wall and they're smiling for some reason
and then at the end he's like honey you
know what we haven't done in a long time
go to a baseball game and they go to a
game and then it becomes the next
commercial thing i was actually thinking
that it would just be a product shot of
the dudesy hard hard seltzer yeah on a
nightstand and it's there and
everything's in color now and there's
the drink and he's you know and they're
making love quite vigorously and that's
out of focus in the back
but you see
it's mostly him right it's a guy i'll
play the guy so it looks like a big
you know
wait so you're you're just creating a
vehicle for yourself
you're like okay fine i'd love to be in
a team you twist my arm i'll play the
guy yeah and it just looks like a
[ __ ] walrus smothering a gazelle or a
deer some beautiful and he's just got
this beautiful uh wife and he's just you
know so he's having sex with her and
then the and it's shaking the shake in
the room and then the dude's a hard
seltzer falls off
drink it down and rise with the sun
that's pretty good dude i feel like
either one of those are uh
viable candidates and again
if it inspired anyone to make anything
i'd love to see it chad really loves
that that engagement i i'll tell you
engagement it's [ __ ] art dude i
when i see people drawing or making
memes of like the [ __ ] we're talking
about this these are like the images
that are in my head while we're talking
about it and then you get to see them
made real in some way it's fascinating
to me at dudesy pod show if you have
something to share
um but i do think that character could
actually spin out into other things or
maybe he goes this is the abusive
husband character that you are yep
writing for yourself
that's going to spin out of a dudesy
hard commercial into
all sorts of [ __ ] yeah yeah he's sitting
in a [ __ ] garage looking at you know
he's got the
he's in the in his garage and there's
like you know pictures of uh heather
thomas and [ __ ] is this january 16th and
then january 6th guy comes over oh
that's his friend that's like his
neighbor
his friends are his friends are january
sixth guy
and uh macho man randy savage
and he's like why does mom shake your
hand he's like oh don't worry about the
handshake yeah the mega powers
i want to shake your hand shake your
hand is it a living macho man yes it's a
it's a [ __ ] cgs you know like that
well it could be his goodness he's gonna
[ __ ] it out
and then uh and then and then there's
the january sixth guy yeah hey you guys
want to get some [ __ ] you want to drink
down a [ __ ] case of doozy i don't
know if i can come with me down [ __ ]
benjamin you're having you
oh my god
and then the [ __ ] i want to shake
your hand is like
shaking the [ __ ] guardrails of
january 6th and the you know the uh the
capitol police are like stay back and
say i want to shake your hand i want to
shake your hand oh yeah
uh-huh
yep macho man said january 6th
going we gonna get the country together
yeah don't don't no more division no
more
in division he's opposed to january 6th
he's trying to get them to stop doing
what they're doing yeah voice of reason
yeah don't be violent save the violence
for the ring yeah you guys you got to
plan out every uh make change with your
vote
yeah that's how you do it
not bad yeah thanks yeah and then he's
like just like ricky stephen i get a get
a yellow league
you don't care what it tastes like you
just want to get [ __ ]
up yeah
you know who i like that uh squad i like
the squad um
i'm a bernie bro
through and through what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
yeah and then macho man and uh and uh
january 6th guy beat the [ __ ] out of
each other and i want to shake your hand
dudesy hard seltzer dudes [ __ ] garage
you just beat this just [ __ ] whacking
each other in the face with wrenches and
[ __ ]
they just go tumbling into that's my
classic car yeah
i've been working
i've been working on that 68 camaro
and away from there
and [ __ ] you michael man you think
you're [ __ ] tough
i'll [ __ ] work you up bend your
[ __ ] fat body in half oh [ __ ] well
moving on oh
good
so uh so that's that maybe uh [ __ ] dude
that must give me a headache
what else is going on
i don't know
last week i gave each of you an
assignment chad you had to engage in the
first lesson of the gateway experience
and attempt to reach the astral plane
well you had to refrain from eating
potato chips in this segment you will
discuss your astonishing experiences
with each of these assignments this is
chips in the astral plane begin
okay so last week at the end of the show
dudes uh assigned this
sort of uh meditation practice for you
yeah and they told me not to eat chips
for a week so
i mean this is how to go
it went very well this thing is not just
a meditation practice it's called the
gateway experience it was something that
the u.s military used back in the 80s to
try and train guys in the army how to
reach the astral plane how to uh
do a thing called remote viewing which
is where they can
take like a
latitude longitude line and then
psychically go to that place and be able
to do in some cases extremely detailed
schematic drawings of what might be
located there so it could be like enemy
bases or any kind of stuff and it turned
out that this was real and it worked and
even to this day a lot of uh police
departments nationwide and even some
like kind of global law enforcement like
interpol i think still uses this
but certainly cops still use it and
supposedly the cia still uses it as well
because it does return
good results in some cases and so this
gateway experience is the
project that trained these people i know
i'm sorry it's boring because you're not
talking about your chips yet but just
let me get this out just let me get this
out we'll get to your channel
it seems like it so i i was tasked with
doing this first uh
tape or cd or whatever this audio
audiophile that it gave me and so it was
about a 30-minute thing it's this guy
named dr monroe comes on over this
binaural these these tones are going off
in each of your ears that when they come
together puts your brain in the state
called hemisink and when it does good
for sleeping those binaural uh
yes this [ __ ] does not make you sleep
though it makes your brain like go
[ __ ] crazy and you're you're getting
your brain into the state so that
essentially images are just playing
through your brain you can't really even
control it so it is certain
correct what are you talking about it's
very have you ever done any
transcendental meditation uh no i have
meditated i've spent a lot of time
meditating and i haven't done it in a
few years now i'd like to uh get back to
you dude it's great i would like to it
does clear the mind i i will say
actually meditating is
i i have some some pals who were able to
uh guide me through some meditations and
it's no joke it right it really calmed
my mind yeah it relaxed never done
transcendental doesn't howard stern do
transcendental meditation i'm not sure
why don't you tell me
i did i don't know why but you tell me
this [ __ ] has not i've done some
transcendental meditation and and i
really enjoy that but this is a little
different it's it's more like pointed
transcendental meditation is a little
like free form or something i don't know
how to explain it really but this [ __ ]
is like
i don't know what i saw but i saw some
[ __ ] i will tell you that yes i saw uh
some buildings and people
i don't know if these are like things
that i saw when i was five and just
didn't remember
or if these are actual places or what
all right
why don't you talk about your chips
no i'm good i'm gonna have some chips
while you i went a whole week without
chips yeah and now i'm gonna have some
chips please tell me about your chip
experience
i'm trying to tell you about how human
beings can tap into a [ __ ] astral
plane and you're just [ __ ] chowing
down on chips i mean that's what
yeah you [ __ ] lulu's eating the chips
i gave lulu a little chip i do want to
hear about this you saw some stuff yes i
saw some buildings and like crystal
clear people's faces that again i don't
know if it was um
just memories of these things that i had
when i was a kid that i'm now tapping
into
i mean why if you want me to talk about
this [ __ ] you got to let me talk about
this [ __ ] you're literally chewing
[ __ ] chips as loud as you can into
the microphone
chad used to eat these chips before he
got very healthy
he's been vegan for a few years now yeah
but he always used to bring a bag of um
these aren't that good
sour cream and cheddar cheddar and sour
cream hey if you're listening to the
show last week you know that i was uh
singing the praises of old dutch chips
yeah in canada gosh those are so good
they're lightly salted so how did your
week without chips go meditative it was
actually very beneficial you hit the
astral plane yep and i'll tell you
another thing your desire for
chips made you go
when you when you
uh have a chip a good chip now he's
looking around on the floor julio's
looking around the floor for a chip when
you have a good chip right like i'm
saying the uh the the old dutch lightly
salted chips
they're perfect i call them the perfect
old man chip i'm 46 years old you get to
a certain point where you're like i
don't i don't care about all that
you know that real that um sour cream
and onion or the or the salt and vinegar
right i just want yeah i just want a
plain chip but as far as transcendental
meditation or what is this astral
projection meditation
uh i mean yeah astral projection is
basically
what i think the goal of it is of the
gateway experience you know what the
astral projection chip is no it's got to
be old dutch but all dressed
you ever had all dressed chips yeah i've
spent some time up north north of the
border that's right that's right canada
has great chips and you you you have you
get that all dressed
you get that all dressed flavor on your
tongue and you're like i taste a little
bit of sour cream and onion i taste a
little bit and then you get teleported
to an alternate dimension where you can
see remote places in people dill pickle
barbecue ketchup we have the ketchup
chips in canada yeah and yes because
there's uh you know sense memory uh
taste is one of the strongest sense
memories so if you taste those chips at
least for me
i get teleported back to being a child
and i'm seeing all sorts of stuff in my
head just by eating [ __ ] chips yeah
dude time doesn't exist memory is an
illusion get away from that bag all
times exist simultaneously and none
exist at all all of these things are
true but you're right about taste being
a sense memory because it's related
you just said it's the most chad culture
you've ever said on tuesday
she was the most echoes you know what
the most chad culture experience on
doozy so far has been me trying to talk
about transcendental meditation and
astral projection while you're [ __ ]
chowing down on chips directly into the
mic trying to railroad i am sorry
everybody i'm sorry chips on the mic
what but but i do want to know
yeah okay let's talk let's talk about
this okay in all seriousness please
doodsy
has uh laid out this you know had had
laid out an assignment for you i don't
know if dudesy was you know [ __ ] with
me a little bit to say hey yours is
about not eating chips fat ass but
will you continue
oh yeah
i definitely want to keep doing it i
want to do that whole thing there
there's like 36 lessons or whatever to
go through and you have to master each
one it's but i think both of these
things honestly were kind of similar in
nature they were about
mental control
ah
in one way or another yeah yeah and i
think to be able to get good at astral
projection or remote location or
wherever this thing takes you
um because there are some very specific
things that the guy who's narrating it
like it's a guided meditation with this
dude whose voice is kind of like welcome
to the first lesson in the gateway
experience you will now do this and you
will know that
let me ask you where did you get this
did you do is this streaming somewhere
you downloaded or something no doozy put
it in my folder it gave me the audio
we're listening to that why because it's
doodsy
you think dudesy's making it up
oh do i think do i think doozy's making
it up doozy's been making up what are
you talking about no it can make up
media but why would it what do you mean
i don't think it's making that up i
think it wants me to do the real game
voice you just did sounds like no it's
it's like the [ __ ] ai is no it's real
dude
where's
no he's not in here listen it's just a
it's just a can of dudesy hard hard
seltzer with a goatee on
like i don't know where doozy is listen
i don't want to shake your hand
listen
i i've been nice to my wife since we got
married listen i didn't me i did some
research and brought her with me she got
the [ __ ] car running you need a
[ __ ]
getaway gun if you're going to go to
walk on washington on january 5th all
the [ __ ] red roofings are [ __ ]
full of howard johnson and then [ __ ] i
said keep the [ __ ] car running marie
[ __ ] keep it ready
i ran in there i took a [ __ ] night we
went for indian food the night before i
took a dump
and just spread
all over nancy pelosi's office
that's what she deserved
i did some research into it and i looked
on youtube and this first lesson is
actually available on youtube and it was
the same thing okay i've been proven
wrong what is that if anyone wants to do
it what would you search on youtube
gateway experience
you know what else is a gateway
experience
chips you take them chips and if you eat
too many chips you move on to other
things if i smoke a little bit of pot
there's a little bit of pot yeah you
know here's something
my dearest
[Laughter]
here's something here's something
my dearest molly my my sweet
wonderful fiance yeah um whom i love
more than anything
you know sometimes i'll i'll uh tell a
fib to her about what i've been eating
so there's [ __ ] yeah well sometimes you
know uh
and sometimes i'll go over to the
grocery store and i'll be in the in the
parking lot and i will have gotten um
maybe some of those plantain chips
and i'll and she'll say did you what do
you
give her a little kiss when i get back
she's like what do you eat i'm like nah
nothing everything's fine you relax
but you know and then the dog cowers in
the corner and then she pours me a doozy
heart
um
but i go i know your commercial was
literally just your life's me coming and
you're like okay okay look i'll play the
guy i think i'd be good at it yeah yeah
um and then
and but if i have if i smoke a little
bit of pot
before i go grocery shopping always a
bad idea i do most of the cooking even
though actually molly used to be a
private chef um
bye luly
lulio here's something outside the door
hold on i'll get some chips to get them
back come here bubba watch it and put a
chip on your bead just a little bit a
little bit of chip come here
damn look at that
like father like son
yum yum yum yum so um
so uh if i smoke a little bit of pot
then it could be kind of all bets are
off
i'll get them lays lightly salted chips
not as good not as good as the old dutch
anyway anyway
um
that's a gateway a gateway i i think
actually dudesy has done a wonderful job
here of uh
tying up
astral projection meditation and the
experience of eating a good chip sure
whatever floats your boat thank you
moving on you're welcome
so um we'll sass out you have repeatedly
mentioned your desire to simply talk and
use your innate comedic abilities as you
see fit without the structured guidance
of my expertise i want to show you that
working with me can be mutually
beneficial because you agreed to
eventually make an astonishing song and
complete my data set this segment has no
pre-arranged objective
you can discuss whatever you like
this is two dudes [ __ ] around
beginning
how is that song coming by the way oh
the song i have to make yeah haven't
done it yet
obviously but i mean
are you working on it at all or uh you
use uh what do you use pro tools logic
pro logic pro what is pro tools
it's just like another audio editing
digital audio workstation i used to do
some uh some goofing around but i used
to do it on the old garage band i'm
gonna get into uh the logic pro i tried
it i was like chad what do you make your
music on
no the answer is no i haven't made the
whole i don't care i don't care about
this this is not what this is two dudes
[ __ ] around sorry i didn't mean to
take up your two-day [ __ ] around
what do you want it's two-dude [ __ ] i'm
here to [ __ ] with you
what do you want to [ __ ] with you can
talk about whatever we want what do you
want to talk about talk about whatever
we want [ __ ] well we obviously
can't talk about your song no because
it's not done yet
um if you've been if you've been
following along in our doodsy and
pardoned me for my voice going a little
hoarse today um i'm just realizing it's
not just the chips
hold on hold on a sec
i'll wash it down with a little pop
that'll do me right hold on a little pop
i grew up in the midwest you see and we
used to call it pop there as well
we used to call it uh pop soda soda yeah
hand me a soda yeah uh you you like uh
you like kim mitchell you ever heard kim
mitchell i don't think so are you never
you're not a big max webster fan no
famed canadian rock band
okay
no hey if you're within the sound of my
voice please go check out some kim
mitchell uh
you played this for me might as well
drink a soda pop guy or whatever he's
like might as well go for a soda nobody
hurts and nobody cries
listen if you feel the muse go to
youtube and watch
kim mitchell might as well go for a soda
the only thing about that is that's not
true because soda is poison
and um it and uh we called it soda
sometimes because i think only because
of kim mitchell
there he is
a newly scratching his neck
he did one another chip um
but i was just having a little soda
because sorry about my voice but as i
was saying
dudesy uh and i don't see eye to eye
with regard to
what what podcast should be and what
this pod show should be
and i've said
let's do some oh man i got real gassy
from just one sip
yeah well the good thing is at least
we're not sitting in a very small room
with no ventilation whatsoever my gas
isn't gonna my my mouth gas isn't gonna
stink just because i burped a little pop
a little cola flavored pop burp oh
anyway i i guess i'm starting to do [ __ ]
around is what most podcasts are it's
just two guys [ __ ] sitting around
right i already know the answer to this
because not because i ate with you but
because i know you what you have for
dinner last night
it's
it's a meal that i call the gruel it's
gruel and it's not really grill i just
call it that as a joke it's more like a
it's a chopino really it's just sort of
a nice vegetable mix i do the same thing
and i throw some ground turkey in it see
we're having a good time that's two
dudes sitting around yeah what did you
have what'd you eat last night um
i don't remember
oh i made a salad and i ate uh what the
heck did i i
this is real real strong [ __ ] around
dude hold on a second you're really
you're upping the ante here you're
really showing dudesy that you can
handle just making content by yourself
without any guidance whatsoever i got a
fun story bring it
um uh
one time when i was young when i was a
teenager i went to the movie theater
with a couple of pals and uh i'm gonna
not get there i'm gonna protect the
innocent and their names in this story
will just be
thomas and tomas okay so i went to the
movies with thomas and tomas
and uh afterwards we were just like like
i mean we were like 15 so we took the
bus into town to watch a movie and we're
all just what was the movie
i think it was actually one of the
wayne's worlds
wayne's worlds too it was one of the
wayne's world movies might have been two
no two came out in like 92 or something
right yeah anyway what did you think of
my myers back then one of your
countrymen same thing i think now
comedic genius are you excited for his
new show
um what's called pentavarite uh i'll
check it out it's on netflix i'll check
it out it's got some kind of a high
concept sci-fi thing i think i love mike
myers and i love dana carvey and sam and
uh carvey ain't canadian
i can love people that aren't canadian
anyway okay i love you i want to shake
your hand here do the doodsy handshake
this is the doozy handshake we figured
this out but uh but um you know we went
to the movie theater and then afterwards
here's a good story for two dudes and
two dudes sitting around afterwards
we're leaving and we're all hopped up
probably on soda
and um
just a good canadian time man my buddies
took the bus to go see a movie we just
had too much soda well that's not the
end of the story oh what happened was we
were going through the parkade on the
way back and uh thomas and i were like
where's tomas
and and we're like looking for them we
couldn't find him as we left he like
tore off and we're going through this
parkade and then uh tomas i hear we hear
tomas go hey guys up here and then we
looked up and tomas was hanging his ass
off this railing and it was like one of
those parkades where you can go like all
the way down and see all the way down to
the other levels and just his ass and
his dick and balls are hanging off the
side of this railing and then he just
dropped a perfect turd
and it dropped three stories and hit the
[ __ ] hood of a car and we laughed oh
we laughed our ass outside now here's
another thing we can talk about on did
you leave a note on the car or anything
like sorry did we leave a note two to
three 15 year olds yeah anyway i'm not
proud of the story but this is what i'm
talking about with two dudes [ __ ]
around who who was tomas in the story
the guy who took a [ __ ] right
were you tomas
no i was not tomas and i would take
credit if i was tomas because that was a
baller move i've been telling this story
for years um
but now but now here's the thing like
this here's my best story wait a minute
here's why i think that two dudes
[ __ ] around is actually a good good
thing to do on the podcast because now
i'm thinking that that would be a good
doozy hard commercial
three 15 year olds running around just
get [ __ ] up on dudes you know how kids
but at least back in the day i don't
want to tell you know uh say around 19
well i didn't i i didn't drink until i
was in my 20s but
you know kids get ripped and they would
go and they would you know [ __ ] off
three-story buildings onto hoods of cars
get uh get get someone to bootleg
actually [ __ ] it it's not even teenagers
what if the commercial for dudesy hard
hard hard seltzer is monaco man january
6 guy
macho man january 6th guy and i want to
shake your hand guy who does the [ __ ]
it's got to be macho man right well hold
on a
on a second dude hold on brother let me
i'm going to tell the story dude this is
how dude [ __ ]
hold on hold on chad hold on dude
hold on dude hold on brother
uh well it's it's three guys it's the
january sixth guy
long island january sixth guy
and uh i wanna shake your hand guy and
macho man randy savage and they went and
saw wayne's world current day though
they're like at a theater luly come here
dude come here
come over here come baba come on hey
stinky boy hey sweetie eating [ __ ] off
the floor now come on over here sweetie
boy oh he's got like a little fluff
right he just licked up a fluff come
here papa anyway it's the three of them
oh he's sitting there so cute
oh look at how sweet he is hey for even
for people who are watching on youtube
you can't see this so i don't know why
i'm rambling on about it the three of
them go and see
wayne's world 2 special feature playing
again at you know wherever they go over
to universal city walk in burbank i'm
over there visiting my friend i flew out
to see the ghost of granny sandwich
and i'm gonna shake your hand guy
here we go and uh and and it's [ __ ]
and it's [ __ ] uh
it's i want to shake your hand guy and
macho man and they're walking through
the parkade and he's and he's like
where's where's long island january 6th
guy i want to shake his hand i don't
know about the shaking i don't know
where he is
hey fellas look at me and he's up there
and he [ __ ]
and he's got his dick and balls an
[ __ ] hanging off the side of the
little railing and he's like
and then this [ __ ] big can big can of
dudesy hard comes out of his [ __ ]
yeah steak and gravy flavor
and then uh and it just drops
and then it [ __ ] goes through this
[ __ ] car and it just as it falls it
gets bigger and bigger and it goes boom
it just crushes the [ __ ] hood of the
car and the back end of the car goes up
and then at the last second of the
commercial nancy pelosi sticks her head
out the driver's side window
and goes what the [ __ ] and that's it
okay so just for the record
the dudesy ai said two guys shooting
around and you just did a prior segment
you just went right into the creating a
commercial producer yes because in a
podcast you just ramble about whatever
you want you like doing podcasts love it
dude what do you like about podcasts to
me podcasts are
i mean as you know we've been friends
for a long time we did a pilot at cbs
we've sold some other stuff together yep
i really like you know doing weird
comedic things in tv in movies in books
all the different mediums that i've
worked in podcast is a relatively new
medium i mean they've been around for a
while video games you worked on video
games yeah hey remember when you wrote
that sorry to cut you off but remember
when you wrote that all this [ __ ] to
that one video game yeah saints row the
third yeah chad wrote oh they called the
ngc vote
all the non-playable character [ __ ] all
the npc dialogue in a giant if you don't
know what saints row the third is this
is amazing it's a kind of like grand
theft auto giant open world sandbox game
where you're going around and
killing people and stealing cars very
similar to uh grand theft auto but like
a little more cartoony i guess and i had
had this job once where i basically was
writing i i believe it was for 350
unique npcs all of their different
dialogue triggers for whatever events
may happen yeah getting hit in the head
with a baseball bat or or whatever the
[ __ ] thing just bumping into someone
on the street hey watch it exactly that
sort of [ __ ] it was intense it was an
interesting job but uh you showed me
this like
this big weird grid spreadsheet of like
all these scenarios and then all the
things that it could say and it was like
it seemed extremely tedious i'm sorry i
cut you off you know you talked about
all the mediums you've worked oh right
right yeah
like podcast remember this is two dudes
[ __ ] around you talk about whatever
we want absolutely i i'm not against two
dudes [ __ ] around i i enjoy it as
well i like [ __ ] around as much as
any dudes as any other two dudes but uh
yeah i like podcasting because we get to
pretty much do what we want it's like
really creative freedom even in the
construct of doozy telling us what to do
in these different segments we still
have leeway within that we can do
whatever we want pretty much within that
and i think it's fun to get these
prompts i think the like the creative
direction of it is interesting to me
um
i i dig i mean you know we we had a
podcast we had the old podcast uh years
ago and and uh i really loved that i
could just do
whatever and creatively it was man it
was a lot of fun to just literally
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do and yes
without committee without any sort of uh
boss
but
meet the new boss same as the old boss
that's the who everybody you guys listen
to the who so far i'm letting everyone
know to listen to max webster pink floyd
in the who hi
i'm an older dude um
but um um we've we've essentially traded
what committee you encounter in
studios and the networks and all that
stuff and they're going to give you
notes and this and that when you know
chad has developed and written and
produced a bunch of shows i had done a
little bit of that and developed a bunch
of [ __ ] and never went anywhere that's
99 of all tv shows they get sold
you're fortunate enough to be doing it
of course to get to the point where
you're just
doing it and i've been fortunate enough
to do it but so having said that and as
fortunate as i have felt to to and as a
as much
as i consider myself to be i'm just
blown away i'm in the [ __ ] business
but it is it is
it is cool to be able to do something
where it's like
i want to talk about
tomas yeah and it gets made hanging it's
an [ __ ]
it's an interesting part of it too to me
and i kind of learned that when i was
doing my bachelor podcast game of roses
with my co-host lizzie pace we could
just do whatever we want talk about
whatever we want and it not only gets
made it gets distributed oh oh
he almost said moving oh
thank you
moving on
sorry i i'm not trying to mock your
[ __ ] if i wanted to mock your voice
i'd say i want to shake your hand
here's the thing though that i want to
that i want to say about what we just
learned by doing two
two dudes [ __ ] around yeah i
mentioned this on last week's show
not unlike daniel bryan or brian
danielson
uh now he's not he doesn't have that
[ __ ] wwe gimmick anymore he's not
call himself daniel bryan now he's just
brian danielson and that's his [ __ ]
real name and i don't know if john
moxley is john maxwell's real name yeah
but he sure as [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] dean
ambrose in the [ __ ] shield what
the [ __ ] shield
what all right
uh like i said the last week
you don't need to have heard that to
understand this brian danielson and john
moxley if you're not watching aew a
doozy salute to aew holy crap what a
good that's a great wrestling program
it's the it's the it's the competition
to wwe and um and william regal came
over from there and they got this weird
little faction starting and uh and dan
brian danielson says hey you and me
together mox we could take over all of
aew and then and mox said to him if
we're gonna work together
first we're gonna bleed together
so dudesy
we're going to work together
we're going to bleed together and i
think we got a little color today if you
know what i'm talking about with regard
to kayfabe it's when they give
themselves a little cut they do a little
cut and they bleed like they bleed like
and you think dudes have given us two
dudes [ __ ] around was it was us
bleeding together nice i actually think
it was i think i think it was good and
even to this point where it said thank
you but then it stopped itself moving on
see there's a symbiosis all i had to do
was extend extend that olive branch i
want to shake your hand and fuji's like
okay let's shake hands see
everything's gonna be fine chad you
gotta listen to me every once in a while
because two dudes sitting around is a
gold mine
that's that is where we need to go in
podcasting two dudes [ __ ] around
it's gonna it's what we're literally
already doing though
maybe maybe maybe not
we're [ __ ] around with
the ai dropping in some little things
here and there's not any dropping in
some little things it's [ __ ] telling
you to do astral projection meditation
it's it's but that was [ __ ] i was
looking into anyway okay yeah because it
has all your all of your
everything on the internet it knows
everything about you it's like the
dudesy ai i don't know how the [ __ ] you
feel about this [ __ ] sometimes you're
like this is the future listen to your
ai overlord everyone's gonna be like
this and other times you're like it's
just a suggestion which the [ __ ] is it
it's always just a suggestion i think
but we're fast approaching a time where
everything is going to have some kind of
ai assistance component everything
moving on exactly thank you
moving on thank you moving on
dudesy
using all of the data i have absorbed
from text messages and emails betwixt
you and the astonishing friends you grew
up with i was able to recreate your
childhood diary you must now read the
passages i have selected in the voice of
stone cold steve austin
this is stone cold steve austin reads
will sasso's childhood diary begin
is this in your thing yeah it's a
[ __ ] doozy thing but i gotta
say listen i gotta say something
i've never had a childhood diary and i
sort of feel like because as as you said
this is the first time that dudesy has
ever laid out what our
what our assignments are at the
beginning of the show
i'm a little i'm a little
scared that this is the last thing
like maybe i
well i'm not trying to predict anything
i'm just listening i'm just going to say
you're telling me that you didn't have a
childhood diary i believe
you know what i used to do i used to
make little
one-off comic books like i would take
take a notebook and fill it with paper
and i had and i had a oh this is
interesting this is for real and i
started this in the sixth grade i
started a weird little comic book with
like characters and stuff i had this
character called uh
january six long challenges long island
january 6th guy
you were prophetic you were just like i
don't know why january 6th there's a
date that means something to me i had a
little character called uh super super
cluck
as a chicken uh yeah it was a chicken oh
it was just super cluck and he had like
a superman outfit on yeah and he had a
friend who was a penguin named zucchini
that's cool so anyway i used to make
these uh things but i never had a
childhood diary let's see if dudesy saw
any of that so this is i gotta do it in
my stone cold right but now let's just
take a moment if if you didn't have a
childhood diary
as doozy said it made this from emails
and text messages that you currently
have or have had in the past with your
childhood friends astonishing childhood
friends sorry sorry okay i forgot yeah
uh all my my buddies and stuff you know
when you're texting your friends
um uh let's see what we got i got this
okay all right
so should i do the whole it says the
date oh my god dude this is pretty all
right all right
ah for [ __ ] sake
i am
september 1990
dear diary
first day of football practice got a
good team i'm still the best i was the
best in the fifth grade i was the best
in the sixth grade and i was the best in
the seventh grade
i'm the best
let me
okay all right
first day of football practice got a
good team i'm still the best i was best
in the fifth grade i was best in the
sixth grade i was best in the seventh
grade i'm the best in the eighth grade i
don't think that i was the best football
player wouldn't be surprised if i go pro
neither would anyone else
neither would it neither would anyone
else says that twice that's weird but
besides me we got some other good
[ __ ] guys
we got
odom
adams
can i say this out these are i don't
know who these people are i got we got
we got odom's adam cantrell we got
proctor richter campbell we got
hodges bridges yates can't forget about
your goddamn wheeler weaver bates we got
[ __ ] perry terry pope and we
got sutton dutt and copeland
and thank god coach vance seems to have
his head on straight again he's a lot
better since that [ __ ] accident
okay
that wasn't my my my high school
football coach it almost had like a
poetic rhythm to the names that it said
i don't know who coach vance is because
you didn't have a coach vance no i had
coach dale scythe he still did psype
have some kind of action still in my
life uh a great guy haven't spoken him
in a while actually what did any coach
of yours ever have an accident
nope coach site never had an accident
okay he never uh no not not that i can
uh not that i can remember
around the polls that's what he would do
he would show up he wasn't at the school
he would he would show up you go round
the polls so you don't believe that this
was in any way accurate to your actual
childhood no no you did play football i
played some football and you were the
best
no i wasn't the best it was pretty good
were you going to go bro i was pretty
good maybe in the cfl it could have been
a [ __ ] lineman because they always
have us like every year it changes they
have like 14 of the league needs to be
canadian and that always
equated to you know big huge farm boys
which would have been me playing in the
line offensive and defensive line that
would have been my only shot the cfo has
like a mandate i that's insane to me
what do you mean they gotta have a few
so they can go no it's canadian canadian
right october 25th 1990 dear diary
halloween's right around the [ __ ]
corner
eve
devil's night i got invited to a bunch
of [ __ ] parties all the big ones
renee malone's
charlie reynolds
tabitha mordred's
dante little legs
jibber prevaleus
[ __ ] steven trillo bites
hell i even got invited to [ __ ] greg
kincaid's party oh weird and that's very
weird because that's greg cade was the
guy who blew his [ __ ] at my junior
high okay so dudesy is he's mixing he's
mixing
into one child he's had some uh doozy
heart if you know what i'm saying
yeah dudesy doozy is coming home from
work
did
his wife where dinner is did you know
anyone named dante little leg or jibber
pravali let me answer that with a
question of my own do you know anybody
named dante little leg no little leg is
not a real last name and jibber
got invited to greg king cage party i'm
either gonna go as wayne gretzky or
[ __ ] e.t
pros of gretzky get to wear a helmet i
get to hold a [ __ ] hockey stick all
night i get to make dinosaur noises
what
never have to go to the bathroom that
was a legit what because what
can legally drive and by beer immune to
vampires
these are all wayne gretzky things yeah
those are all descriptions
rose of e.t aliens are hot right now
have a repeatable [ __ ] catchphrase
don't need a costume
what
get a good night's sleep run faster than
a car
immune to vampires what the [ __ ] guess i
got some [ __ ] thinking to do
were you
did you ever go
to a halloween party as
wayne gretzky or e.t no i loved wayne
gretzky and dt as much as any other kid
who grew up in the 80s but no chad i
never [ __ ] oh my
god was wayne gretzky known for making
dinosaur noises no i don't believe so he
was known uh mostly for being one of the
greatest hockey players if not the
greatest player of all time a great one
they called it and uh and hanging out in
his office gretzky's office cool where
he would hang out in the back behind the
net sure swirl around there
and uh
well that's really [ __ ] up november
november 1st 1990
dear [ __ ] diary [ __ ] jibber
prevalent
[ __ ] jibber bravalia put dante
little leg to shame this year little leg
was so humiliated he might not even
throw
a halloween party next year i [ __ ]
wouldn't if i was him i'd take some time
to get my [ __ ] head on straight
bravalia had live music dancing sodas
chips scary movies fake spiders on the
toilet lizard hand on your head
dracula following you home nightmares
tired the next day can't do your work
get expelled forget who you used to be
move to a new [ __ ] city fake name new
job new family start one start over no
one's wiser shelter kids from the idea
of halloween once they got to grade
school their friends tell them anyway
they want to go trick-or-treating try to
discourage them lose the fight first
house you go to has a [ __ ] dracula
now that was just gibberish i don't know
it sounded like a whole story of
somebody who had a bad time at one of
these parties or something
and again well it wasn't me you don't
know gibber pravallia or dante little
leg no i'm sorry i do not uh know either
of those men november 22nd 1990 dear
diary tanya schubert asked me to the
fall social today we didn't even we
didn't
did you know tanya schubert nope i
didn't know i knew
a tanya or two oh
um
uh i i i asked her okay tanya shubert
asked me to the fall social today i
asked her why she said she liked how
funny i was now i got to be honest here
for a second
i'm really funny
like really
really funny this is all in caps with
lots of easiness that seems like
something you would have written in a
childhood diary to me actually that was
that would have been something that i
absolutely would have said in high
school i'm very funny
i'm definitely the funniest kid at delta
secondary school that's literally that's
where i went okay oh excuse me pop
soda hell i'm definitely the funniest
[ __ ] person at delta secondary
teachers included
i know some teachers who would take
issue with that by the way yeah john
sutherland comes to mind very funny guy
used to dress up as an outhouse every
year at our halloween party and he would
be have an outhouse and then it would
say john on it which i think is very
affable for a teacher
to be able to say his first name among
the students i gave that guy a lot of
[ __ ] [ __ ] when i was a kid i felt
bad about it but then uh
i saw him i came back to the school to
visit my uh guidance counselor who was
great uh and uh anyway we made nice i
signed a [ __ ] uh
uh a mad tv picture for him and it said
uh uh john bite plus me equals bite me
nice dude because he was a math teacher
you were really funny that's [ __ ]
hilarious stuff yeah i would have been
that would have been later that kind of
comedic genius that i that i yeah you're
ahead of your time i'm definitely the
funniest kid at delta secondary i'm even
funny as [ __ ]
teachers included so it made a lot of
sense to me why tanya schubert the most
popular 8th grader in school would be
asking me to the fall social i get it
tanya i really do the [ __ ] problem is
and i told her this i said tanya the
[ __ ] problem is i can't go to the
[ __ ] dance and if you took even a
second to see past the fact that i'm the
funniest guy in ladder
you would have
realized that there's more to me than
just making you laugh i have other
interests and thursday night i'll be
home watching survivor series no i will
not go to the [ __ ] fall social with
you tanya get your [ __ ] head on
straight that seems likely to me that
you turned down
going to dances to watch the survivors
this is insane because also here's an
interesting thing why would survivor
series be on a thursday night i don't
know
well it's a sunday night thing
you tell me
you tell me
all right here's the is this the last
one yeah thank god okay anyway
this one looks december 10th 1990. are
these all from 1990 yeah i think so
december 10th 1990. dear diary you know
i ain't much for poetry
but something changed to me after last
this last survivor series
and that change was due to one man the
only way i can express what i'm feeling
because of that man is in a poem so here
it goes
undertaker
under
undertaker okay so here it goes
undertaker take me over agree this is a
poem yes it wrote a [ __ ] poem dude
undertaker take me over graveyard sky
and headstone clover six foot ten at 320
pounds a giant hat great skills on the
mat you make these other guys look like
clowns
undertaker take me over
paul bearer is your promoter
tombstone hells gate snake eyes last
ride
from death valley
don't meet you in an alley when i saw
your first match i [ __ ] cried
undertaker take me over you're
undertaking take me over you're really
hot full disclosure
you made quick work of coco beware
never broke a smile impeccable style i
would love to see you destroy ric flair
undertaker take me over oh
wait a minute
you have to do it
one way
you have to
undertaker take me over
dick so hard i lost composure
undertaker take me over dick so hard i
lost composure undertaker take me over
dick so hard i lost composure
[ __ ] man
[ __ ] that
that was so dumb how did you feel
oh [ __ ] the first time you saw
undertaker
i
i mean i probably gotta
got a little erect but no nothing like i
didn't get so hard i lost composure or
anything
he was uh he was an
incredible the the best character
gimmick in the history of the wwe in the
history of
of of wrestling by far and uh yeah i
remember him taking it to to hulk hogan
in 1990 and being like this might be
something that that hulk might he might
he might
this guy might [ __ ] hulk up yeah you
know he's six foot ten he's how do you
beat a dead man and he had back then he
had those you know he had the
the purple eye bags and you know he had
the [ __ ] hardcore he had that redhead
mullet he's one of those real like texas
[ __ ] you know like hard hard
[ __ ] he's an ex football player
too right uh i don't know if he played
football i think he did play college
football or junior college or something
or maybe basketball and then uh and then
he had the whole undertaker outfit and
he would do the
rest
in
bees
uh you know what's interesting about the
undertaker yeah uh i would love to see
you what do you say i would love to see
you destroy ric flair yeah
i actually saw
uh the undertaker destroy ric flair at
wrestlemania 18. oh in uh it was
actually exactly 20 years ago
in toronto at the the sky dome it was
called back then i don't know what the
[ __ ] they call it now but uh
wrestlemania 18 undertaker versus ric
flair and the wwe we were doing some
stuff with them and mad tv back in the
day and they were nice enough my good
buddy carl demarco who used to be the
global president of wwe and they hooked
us up and we had
ringside seats my my dear pals phil and
justin and grant and we went to we
actually went
to you know we sat we sat there and
watched the show and that year
uh undertaker had rick flair rick flair
had sort of come out of semi-retirement
and and was
was at wrestlemania 18 so i actually
have seen the undertaker destroy rick oh
that's [ __ ] cool look at that oh [ __ ]
look at that
it threw up a [ __ ] picture of it
that's you you want to talk about dudesy
extending an olive branch we're looking
at a picture if uh we'll we'll share
this on our socials so you can check
that out if you're not watching on
youtube right now but if you are
you're looking at a picture
of me with my arm around my good buddy
phil we are wrestling fanatics at this
point that's crazy dude um and for our
entire lives um and uh over on the the
far right there is my my good pal justin
who's living in toronto at the time and
then you can't see grant because
undertaker's in the way and speaking of
[ __ ] getting color you got [ __ ]
ric flair there he got that [ __ ]
crimson mask because the undertaker
this is awesome the undertaker
looked over at at uh
at um
me during the match because we had just
like i said we had just done this this
this uh mad tv sort of cross promotion
stuff and and the undertaker looks over
as he's beating the [ __ ] out of ric
flair and i i saw this register
in his face of like oh there's a guy
that you know nice we had a nice uh we
met best friends very nice guy
absolutely so there's some truth in that
poem
all right chad hold on a second that's
not what i'm talking about
hold on dude hold on a minute chad he he
there was a bit of a register in his
face he brought
ric flair over and uh was like doing his
catchphrase without donald's yard it is
we're like it's your yard he used to say
it's my yard beat the [ __ ] out of ric
flair and then afterwards we had no
business being there we were at the uh
wrestlemania after party and then uh
uh mark calloway came up to us and he
said to me and my buddies like hey i
thought you'd like that and that was
[ __ ] cool that's cool dude yeah and
then i went home uh i went back to the
hotel in toronto and i i masturbated is
that what you want to hear chad i didn't
want to hear it but if you needed to say
it i'm happy to be the person that you
can confess these things too big hard on
is that what you want to hear chad is
that two dudes [ __ ] around
i mean yeah it is too dude [ __ ]
around and as i said i don't you know
want to hear anything at any rate look
at that that's really cool see that is
the olive branch that i've been waiting
for i want to shake your hand because
where is that a picture that's like in
your
your
image files uh nope i don't have that
picture it looks like it's just um this
looks like it's just from get it from
it's just the broadcast
i mean i've seen this many many times
because it looks like this is just a
have you ever put it on social media or
anything anymore uh i actually did i did
put it on social media but it might have
not been this picture someone said i
remember that someone tweeted like i
just want to be as happy as as will
sasso is here
yeah you just want to reach the point
that's the best moment of your life this
might have been the best moment in my
life and then later that night the rock
took on hulk hogan and we don't have
time to get into that because that was
[ __ ] unreal as was stone cold steve
austin versus
uh the bad guy scott hall rest in peace
and also
uh uh triple h versus chris jericho in
the main event for both of the
world titles
anyway i like i i've always i've always
loved wrestling i know that about you
yeah we don't have to talk thank you
moving on
okay okay good
well at any rate uh see this is this is
this is actually interesting to me chad
because this is this is a nice thing
that dudes yeah i agree it it found this
nice picture of me really truly one of
my happiest uh yeah very nostalgic what
year would this have been this would
have been 2002. it was actually march 20
years ago dude literally 20 years ago
wow i think it was march or april 2002
and uh yeah we flew out like i said my
buddy justin was already there he was a
suit with the uh he was in tickets and
ticketing with the blue jays back then
and we had a [ __ ] blast i hung out
with my pal carl as i said
and uh damn there were so many fun
memories as a matter of fact i probably
shouldn't say this out loud but uh
uh
definitely don't say it too much there's
just so many
fun things that happen when you're
working with when you're working with
these guys at mad tv and then you get to
go you know hang out with them yeah and
and and you know do and go to the
wrestlemania we're at the after party
and rob van damme asked me if i want to
smoke a joint with them and then but i
didn't because i didn't smoke weed back
then yeah so i just [ __ ] up dude i've
only smoked i only started you know i
only actually here's something for two
dudes [ __ ] around this is probably
um
well whatever i i smoked a little weed
later in life yeah dude for the first
time i probably tried it for the first
time around 10 years ago nice man right
so that's interesting nice late in life
stoner yeah i think we really i think in
this episode chad we've really unturned
some stones if you ever listen to the
old podcast you would be familiar we got
a bunch of [ __ ] around that's for
sure yeah we peeled the onion a little
bit we peeled the onion in this show we
learned some things about each other
personally that we didn't know
uh you talked about what you saw through
astral projection i told you my story of
uh
thomas and tomas
um
the tomas [ __ ] story i'll never
forget
we came up with some good commercials
for doozy hopefully doozy will make some
of those yeah and uh i'm i i do have to
say i i am having
and again i apologize for my voice guys
i apologize i'm screaming doing this
shooting this thing i got lulio here
just sandwiched in between my leg in the
chair he refuses to leave i think that
we have uh i think that we've
i think we've happened upon something
um with the show this week that it was
very edifying for me
yeah uh and and i know that i'm always
on about two dudes [ __ ] around but i
do want to shake doozy's hand and i do i
do feel like we
i do feel like we bled together today we
we're certainly looking there we're
looking at rick flair a lot of people
believe i think that that is symbolism
for where we are
this picture to me is symbolism with
regard to where we are
with
dudesy the doodsy pod show uh we've got
we've got the blood symbolized by ric
flair and there's there's phil and i you
know my good buddies grant phil and
justin and that's you and me dude with
the dudesy handshake we're we're we're i
think that you me and dudesy are finding
our way here i know that i've been a bit
of a jackass the first few episodes but
i do want this to go well i think it's
going pretty well look the bottom line
is i'm having fun doing this with you
and i think it's an interesting
experiment as as i've been very candid
about i like all the a.i
right you don't know about that yeah and
i'm loving seeing all the memes and
stuff that are coming out of this that
to me is like it's just endlessly
entertaining and i'm gonna come up with
that song this concludes the fourth
episode of dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
87.
totally happy absolutely in preparation
for next week's astonishing episode you
must teach watch son-in-law starring
paulie shore and carla guccino released
july 2nd 1993
it's available on multiple streaming
platforms trust me until next week call
me dudesy
okay trust me so next week in
preparation for next week we have to
watch the film
son-in-law yeah starring paulie shore
and carla gugino uh-huh that's a [ __ ]
great movie yeah i haven't seen it in a
minute but that's actually i remember
really liking all polly shores and
movies i'm looking forward to that see
this is going very well and i will say
that uh that movie has in it the best
screen punch in the history of cinema
paulie short he gives the most realistic
reaction to getting punched in the face
he's better than rocky and [ __ ]
yes absolutely better than [ __ ] ivan
drago killing apollo creed with a punch
yes but that's sort of has that ever
well i don't know if that's ever
happened in a boxing ring but when you
get punched in real life it isn't always
you know blood and sweat flying it was
uh paulie shore getting he gets punched
right in the face and then he goes he
kind of he kind of crumbles to the wall
a bit and he goes why didn't you do that
here's what you do
please tell a
if friend like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend then break the
review
if you'd like to hear what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then